I've been getting caker sores on my tongue. They're irritating sore. What are
they from? What could I do to heal them? Well L, lysine, it's going to be the
acid can be helpful for caker sores also taking calcium lactate and putting
them directly on the caker sores have been known to help. Caker sores are
from a change in pH in your mouth. That's what they're from. While caker sores are
from herpes simplex virus that lives in the nerve ganglion in the trigeminal nerve
ganglion in your up by your cheek so that herpes virus lives there and it comes
out where there's a change in pH in your mouth. So that's why people get a
colsar after they like suck on a lemon they'll get a colsar because it changes the
pH. It's a drastic change in pH in their mouth. So whenever you have a drastic
change in pH in your mouth a colsar could come out. That's why people could go
months or even years or little colsar that also they get a colsar when they eat
something like really super spicy or they have some lemon juice or they drink
something that would you know acidic or alkaline that could throw off the
pH in the mouth and that just gives the opportunity. So herpes simplex is an
opportunity opportunistic organism and it comes right down in the trigeminal
nerve and you know forms of blister in the mouth. That's what it is. So elizine can
be helpful. There's you could probably Google a bunch of other different
actual things that could be helpful with it too.